a ballot for nursing strikes by the
Royal College of Nursing has failed to
reach the legal threshold that it needs
to have in order for those strikes to go
ahead Let's cross live to Skies Ashley
hurunag who is in The Newsroom for us so
Ashton does this mean that the nurse's
strikes are now off it does bring them
to an end certainly when it comes to
those Royal College of Nursing members
who are from England at least and it
would have affected those trusts in
England but also NHS employers too it
does bring that strike action to an end
they had started striking last December
the first time they decided to do so in
their 106 year history what we've just
learned in the last few minutes that
Union uh the Union's ballot of its
members has failed to reach its mandate
it does mean that that strike action has
been called off they had been balloting
their members through the usual postal
ballot system post postal vote started
landing on the doorsteps of its members
throughout the past few weeks and the
deadline for it had been on Friday day
and what they needed was to pass their
50 threshold that would have meant uh a
hundred and fifty thousand of its
members having at least Taken part in
that vote and then over 50 of them
should have at least voted for it or if
they had had a majority from that it
would have meant strike action could
continue but they only had a 43 turnout
it's worth saying the General Secretary
of the Royal College of Nursing the RCN
Pat Cullen had said she was confident
they would surpass that 50 voting
threshold but she did voice concerns
over that possibility of perhaps both
voting um papers not getting to its
members sooner or soon enough and she
did raise those early concerns that
perhaps the threshold maybe wouldn't be
reached she was voicing sort of the idea
of perhaps introducing an online voting
system her argument was look if
conservative party members could vote
for the next prime minister as they did
last year using an online tool why
couldn't members within unions do the
same this though no strike action
certainly when it comes to nurses as I
say in England members of the Royal
College of Nursing is good news for the
government no strike is good news for
them it'll certainly be a win as far as
Wishy sunak is concerned it's worth
saying that there had been an acceptance
of the pay deal that they their latest
pay deal brought to the table to
certainly Health unions 14 Health unions
had voted for it unite another Union and
also the RCN who decided to reject that
uh offer that had been put on the table
that was sitting about five percent plus
a one-off payment
and because the government ultimately
want to avoid spiraling wages and they
want to uh you know keep inflation down
they will see this as good news the fact
that there certainly will be no strike
action up to the end of the year but it
will I suppose the question is will this
be the end the campaign of industrial
action when it comes to nurses in
England we'll have to wait and see we
will and Ashley as you're talking the
statements come out from Pat Cullen she
says that she is disappointed obviously
in this vote but she says you've seen
the Prime Minister this afternoon to
hear him out to ask him the questions
you wanted answering I know Steph
Morales low and the staff in crisis is
set to worsen she says we've started
something special the voice of nursing
has never been stronger we're going to
keep using it so that statement there
from Pat Cullen from the Royal College
of Nursing